learn about Vector embeddings which
transform Rich data like words or images
into numerical vectors that capture
their Essence this course from anikubo
will help you understand the
significance of text embeddings showcase
their diverse applications guide you
through generating your own with open Ai
and even delve into integrating vectors
with databases by the end you'll be
equipped to build an AI assistant using
these powerful representations so let's
begin hi everyone and welcome to this
course all about vector embeddings by
the end of this course you will be able
to understand what Vector embeddings are
how they are generated as well as
understand why we even care about them
in the first place we are going to do
this thanks to visual explainers as well
as some hands-on experience by building
out a project that uses Vector
embeddings to submit your understanding
of them by the end
my name is Anya Kubo and I'm a software
developer and course creator on YouTube
as well as on codewithanyu.com and I'm
going to be your guide to this hot but
slightly complex topic so before we get
going let's just have a quick look at
what this course will cover so first off
we're going to learn what Vector
embeddings are in the first place and
what they're used for after we
understand that I will show you what a
real Vector embedding looks like and
show you how to make one yourself and
after that I will delve into why
companies might want to store Vector
embeddings in a database as well as show
you how to store Vector embeddings in
your own database just as a company
focused on AI word next we will take a
quick look at a popular package called
Lang Chen that will help us with the
next part of making an AI assistant in
Python and if you don't know any python
don't worry I'm going to talk you
through it step by step okay so a lot to
learn but by the end you should be an
expert in this aspect of AI development
so what are we waiting for let's do it
what are vector embeddings in computer
science particularly in the realm of
machine learning and natural language
processing or NLP for short Vector
embedding is a popular technique to
represent information in a format that
can be easily processed by algorithms
especially deep learning models this
information can be text pictures video
and audio and much more let's look at
text embeddings first so in terms of
text we can create a text embedding that
will give us more information about our
word such as its meaning that computer
can understand a word will go from
looking like this for us humans to this
for computers so essentially the word
food is represented by an array of lots
and lots of numbers but why do this well
think about it this way say we have this
text right here diary went to town on
foot she set off early in the morning to
beat the rush to the shop she wanted to
be sure to get the best lettuce and
tomatoes for her grandfather's recipe
now say you want a computer to scan this
for words with the closest meaning if
you ask a computer to come back with a
word similar to food for example you
wouldn't really expect it to come back
with letters or tomatoes right that's
what a human might do when thinking of
similar words to food a computer is much
more likely to look at the words in the
text lexicographically kind of when you
scroll through a dictionary and come
back with foot for example this is kind
of useless to us we want to capture
words semantic meaning so the meaning
behind the word Texas embeddings
essentially represent that thanks to the
data captured in the super long array by
creating a text embedding of each word I
can now find words that are similar to
food in a large Corpus of texts by
comparing text embedding to text
embedding and returning the most similar
ones so words such as lettuce instead of
foot will be more similar now you might
still be wondering what even are these
numbers what does each one represent
well that actually depends on the
machine learning model that generated
them to understand how these numbers can
help us find words that are similar
however let's look at this fantastic
visual explainer from Jay Alamar I
absolutely love this explainer so full
credit to him for these next few
illustrations it really is great imagine
you are also conduct a personality test
similar to that of the Big Five
personality traits test that rates your
openness agreeableness conscientiousness
negative emotionality and extroversion
the test requires a score from 0 to 100
on each of the five traits in order to
get a good understanding of a person's
personality let's start by looking at
the extroversion trait first
imagine Jay gives himself a 38 out of
100 as its introversion extroversion
score let's show this in one dimension
like so on the left
now let's switch this out to be a score
of minus one to one now it is hard to
know a person from just one personality
trait right so let's add another one and
then turn another dimension the aguria
winners score of a person for example or
any of the other five traits great and
already you can start to get a better
understanding of Jay's personality now
say we have three people here are their
personalities plotted out based on two
personality traits so we can see them on
a two-dimensional graph and we can also
see them on the right in numeric
representations from minus one to one
now CJ got hit by a bus and we miss our
friend I want to replace them with a
person with a similar personality dark I
know but you get the idea
when dealing with these numerical values
or vectors a common way to calculate a
similarity score is using cosine
similarity this is the formula for
getting cosine similarity
using cosine similarity you will see
person one is more similar in
personality to J than person two but
still two personality traits probably
aren't enough let's use all five trait
scores so we can use five dimensions for
our comparison
now the problem is this is kind of hard
to draw let alone think about on a graph
this is a common challenge in machine
learning where we often have to think in
higher dimensional space however cosine
similarity still works so we can get a
numerical value by passing through the
vectors for each person we want to
compare to each other into the formula
to get one numeric value which
represents similarity
so now by comparing J to person 1 J to
person 2 and J2 person 3 we can see
which person is most similar to him
great now that we understand this
concept let's look at the actual text
embedding
so for example this is the word food
generated by open AIS create embedding
so as you can see it's an array of lots
and lots of numbers from -1 to 1. the
meaning behind each numeric
representation varies based on which
model generates them here are some of
the other models you can use to create
text embeddings so you've got open AI as
we've seen huertevac and glove so as we
now know we can use these text
embeddings to compare them to other text
embeddings just like we did with the
example of comparing personality trait
to personality trait apart from instead
of capturing a personality the meaning
of a word is captured instead
there is another cool benefit to Turning
words into numeric representation one of
them being that we can now apply math to
them take for instance this now
well-renowned example so King minus man
plus woman equals Queen
so for example here you can see how you
can take the word King and minus the
word man and replace it with the word
woman and you get Queen this is truly
incredible and it's all thanks to text
embeddings
we can use code in order to pass through
the words King and woman and subtract
man and then we get a bunch of words
returned to us each with a similarities
score
Queen is the most similar and hence it
has the highest score pretty cool right
let's move on by actually talking about
what Vector embeddings can be used for
so far we have looked at Texan beddings
but Vector embeddings actually cover a
lot more text is just one of the things
that we can vectorize we can vectorize
sentences documents notes and graphs
images and even our faces we have word
embeddings like we just seen this is one
of the most popular applications why are
the baddings like what back or glove
convert words into dense vectors where
semantically similar words are closer in
the vector space for instance we saw
king and queen would have vectors that
are closer than King and paper
next we also have document and sentence
embeddings methods like Dr vac but and
sentence but can represent whole
documents or sentences as vectors this
can be used in document classification
semantic search and more next we also
have graph embeddings nodes in a graph
can be represented as vectors
applications include recommendation
systems social network analysis and more
here are some of the primary
applications of vector embeddings we
have recommendation systems embeddings
can be used to represent users and items
like movies books or products the
similarity between user and item
embeddings can help in making
personalized recommendations
we also have anomaly detection if you
can represent data as vectors you can
measure instances or similarities to
detect outliers or anomalies in data we
also have transfer learning pre-trained
embeddings especially in the context of
deep learning models can be transferred
to another task to Kickstart learning
especially when the target task has
limited data and also amazingly we have
visualizations high dimensional data can
be converted into 2D or 3D embeddings
using techniques like tsne or PCA to
visualize clusters or relationships in
the data we also use it for information
retrieval by embedding both queries and
documents in a shared space one can find
documents that semantically match the
query even if they don't share exact
keywords and of course we can use them
for natural language processing tasks
tasks like text classification sentiment
analysis named entity recognition and
machine translation benefit from
embeddings as they capture semantic
information and relationship between
words we also have audio and speech
processing audio clips can be converted
to embeddings for tasks like speaker
identification speech recognition or
emotion detection and finally we can use
it for facial recognition face
embeddings can represent a face as a
vector making it easier to compare faces
and recognize identities so a lot of
things that Vector embeddings can be
used for we're going to create a few of
Our Own in the lesson coming up but the
main takeaway here is that the core
advantage of vector embeddings is that
they provide a way to transform complex
multi-dimensional and often discrete
data into a lower dimensional continuous
space that captures semantic or
structural relationships within the
original data
next up how do we generate Vector
embeddings I'm going to show you how
using openai's Create embedding okay so
here we are on open AI so please go
ahead and log in or sign up if you
haven't before and you'll be taken to
this landing page now once here what we
are going to do is interact with the API
so just go ahead and click that and the
first thing you will need to do is just
make sure you have an API key so under
your username here just view your API
keys and go ahead and create a new
secret key I'm gonna call this demo key
like so so that is the name of my key
and I'm going to create a secret key and
save this somewhere safe so please go
ahead and do the same just save your API
key and once you're done with that click
done
you can of course delete previous API
keys to revoke access to them so that's
what I'm going to be doing with this one
so that you can't use it in the future
it will be deleted
now once you have that let's go back to
our API reference and what we're going
to do is create embedding so let's click
on embeddings here here's the URL if you
are lost just copy that into your
browser and we are going to be using the
embedding object so essentially here is
the code that we're going to use so it's
right here we have in node.js you can
have it in python or you can also have
it in curl it is up to you whichever one
you would prefer to do so let's just go
ahead and use this version first so this
is what we're going to be using this is
the request we're going to write and
this is the response that we are going
to get based on the input we passed
through okay so essentially the food was
delicious and the waiter dot dot dot is
now represented by this embedding this
array of numbers right here
so let's go ahead and do it I'm going to
copy this just make sure that it's
copied let's get up our terminals I'm
just going to make this a little bit
bigger for you let's paste that in and
now here we need to replace the open AI
API key with our own
so let's just go ahead and do that
it's going to navigate
to that piece of text
delete it all just like so and paste it
and let's just use the same input for
now so hit enter and amazing so there is
the array of essentially numbers from -1
to 1 that make up the food was delicious
and the waiter dot dot so there we go
there is that whole object the full
thing right here
it is also telling us how many tokens we
have used in order to create that so
great I'm just going to clear that out
so let's paste that in again in fact
what we can do is just press up and now
let's change the input to something else
so for example let's just use an example
from the beginning of this tutorial
let's just go with food
so third hit enter and that is the text
embedding for food okay it's this whole
array and we have used exactly one token
to create that amazing
now it's time to look at vectors and
databases with the rapid adoption of AI
and The Innovation that is happening
around large language models we need at
the center of it all the ability to take
large amounts of data contextualize it
process it and enable it to be searched
with meaning
generative AI processes and applications
that are being built to natively
incorporate generative AI functionality
or rely on the ability to access Vector
embeddings a data type that provides a
semantics necessary for AI to have a
similar long-term memory processing to
what we have allowing it to draw on and
record information for complex task
execution
as we now know Vector embeddings are the
data representation that AI models such
as large language models use and
generate to make complex decisions like
Memories in the human brain there is
complexity Dimension pattern and
relationships that all need to be stored
and represented as part of the
underlying structures which make all of
this difficult to manage
that is why for AI workloads we need a
purpose-built database or brain designed
for highly scalable access and
specifically built for storing and
accessing these vector embeddings Vector
databases like data Stacks astrodb built
on Apache Cassandra are designed to
provide optimized storage and data
access capabilities specifically for
embeddings
now that we understand how important it
is to store these vectors in the right
type a database let's get to setting one
up ourselves in preparation for creating
our AI assistant so let's do it so fast
off I'm just going to navigate to data
stacks and log in please go ahead and
sign up if you haven't already this is
what your screen should look like once
you are signed in and you can see all
your options here as well along with
your username and so on so as you will
see I've previously created a bunch of
databases on here already but don't
worry I'm going to show you how to get
started completely from scratch
so all you're going to do is Click
create database here and make sure you
have Vector database selected and once
you have that it's super simple just go
ahead and name your database making sure
to use the correct characters so for
example it won't let you use certain
ones you have to use ones that are
allowed you will get a little prompt
message if you do use an incorrect one
I'm just going to go ahead and call my
database Vector database
now we have to create a key space name
that will go inside our database and
once again just make sure to name it
with the correct conventions so I'm just
going to call it search as that was what
we are creating we are creating a vector
search database so I'm just being super
literal with my naming conventions and
now I'm going to pick a region that is
closest to me so I'm going to go ahead
and select Us East one and then just
click create database and that's it
that's really all there is you will see
my database is pending right here we
have done it we created our database I'm
going to leave that running and come
back to it when it's time to use it and
pending has gone from pending to active
for now let's carry on with a little bit
of learning
before we dive into creating an AI
project I want to talk to you a little
bit about line chain
Lang chain is an open source framework
that allows AI developers to have better
interactions with several large language
models or llms like open ai's gbt4 for
example we can use the M python or
JavaScript which is great news for us
Developers what do I mean by better
interactions however well for one it
allows developers to create chains which
are logical links between one or more
llm
you can even use it to load documents
such as PDFs or csvs for example to
change to each other or an llm heck you
can even use it to split up documents
and much more you can have basic chains
or more advanced chains we'll be
creating our own chain soon enough in
this course
for now just know that langtune's
superpower lies in allowing you the
developer to chain together different AI
large language models external data and
prompts in a structured way in order to
create cool and Powerful AI applications
such as an AIS system for example that
not only uses data from the internet but
perhaps an essay that you wrote as well
that we can then feed into it in order
for the AI assistant to answer questions
about it too
okay so we finally gathered enough
knowledge in order to proceed in
building an AI assistant built in Python
so let's go ahead and do it just to
recap this AI assistant is going to
essentially be an AI assistant that will
help us search for similar text in a
data set okay so once again we are going
to be able to get some data break it up
into little chunks save it in a database
in order for us to essentially perform
Vector search on it thanks to packages
such as Lang chain don't worry if that's
a lot I'm going to be explaining
everything step by step as we do it so
first off let's go back to our database
in order to continue with this tutorial
so we've already created a serverless
database the next thing we're going to
do is actually learn to connect with it
from an external source and in order to
do that we need to essentially get our
token so please go ahead and get that
token we need to go to the connect Tab
and we're simply going to get an
application token using the generate
token button in the quick start section
so you can save this in any way you want
just make sure it's saved somewhere safe
now once we have got that token saved we
need to get a secure connect bundle okay
so just go ahead and do that get your
bundle and once again save this
somewhere safe this time however we're
going to down with the secure bundle
because we're going to point to this
somewhere on our computer so just
download the whole thing onto your
computer into your downloads wherever
you want
great now that we have that once again
we are going to have to get our API key
so as a refresher all you're going to do
is head over to the openai.com page
and then once you have signed in you
will see this platform and you're going
to go to API and then once again we are
going to be working with embeddings
however we are not going to be doing a
call request from here we are going to
Simply feed in our API token in order
for Lang chain to do its thing instead
so just go ahead and navigate to your
username view your API Keys create a new
one so this time I'm just going to call
it demo copy this key okay and keep it
somewhere safe and then let's go back to
data Stacks once more
okay
so great we have done everything that is
to be done here now let's create a
python script using Lang chain and
Castor IO
so I'm just going to go ahead and get up
my terminal once more and navigate to a
directory where I want to store this
this time I'm going to store it in a
another directory which is going to be
webstorm projects and I'm going to
create a
directory I'm going to call it search
python so I'm going to use the mukter
command and then I'm going to go into
that project so using the CD command I'm
just going into search python or
whatever you called your project and
then I'm just going to open it up using
Code dot which is the shortcut to
opening this up in vs code
and great
so once we are in vs code I'm just going
to make sure that this is enabled for
python
so in order to work with python files
let's just go ahead and create a python
file first I'm going to call it index.py
giving it the py extension so that our
code editor knows to treat this as a
python file
next I'm just going to go here and click
on the prompt and this has prompted me
it's saying that you know it's
recognizing we're working with python
and it's asking us to install the
recommended python extension so I'm just
going to go ahead and install that and
that is installing for me right now
great once we have done that we are also
prompted with a little checklist so I'm
going to go ahead and just run through
this it's telling me to create a python
file which we've already done so the
next thing we're going to do is actually
add a python environment so let's go
ahead and do that I'm just going to go
with the first one
so great once we have made our
environment we can essentially do stuff
like this so I'm going to write print
hello so just go ahead and do the same
as me this is a python script a very
simple one and now if we run this by
essentially pressing this little plus
sign right here that will run the script
and you will see Hello being printed in
our terminal okay so that's really it
everything's now ready to go we've been
set up correctly great
so now let's get to the media stuff now
in order to install packages you can't
write it in the script here okay if I go
ahead and write pip install and all the
packages packages python packages that
we need and hit plus that will not work
we need to do this in the terminal so
just go ahead and paste that in like so
just copy it out and hit enter and that
will do its thing and install all the
packages that we need the packages once
again are Cas IO Data sets Lang chain
open Ai and tick token so go ahead and
wait for that to do its thing it will
take some time and once it's ready we
should be able to continue with our
tutorial
great now I'm just going to go ahead and
rename this file for readability okay
I'm going to rename this to mini.qa you
will see there's another directory above
me that has been generated with
everything that we've done so just go
ahead and rename your file if you want
to continue having everything the same
as me you don't have to though that is
completely up to you
great
the next thing I'm going to do is just
ask you to copy this code so here are
some variables that we're going to need
in order to continue with this tutorial
so we have the Astro DB secure bundle
part we've already downloaded this onto
our computers so that is something that
we're going to have to point to and the
next thing we're going to have is our
astrodb application token as well as our
Azure DB client ID okay so these are
things we're going to fill out from the
stuff that we saw earlier from our
secret things that we downloaded some
other things that we're gonna have to
add are our astrodb key space name as
well as our open AI API key which we
just recently saved as well and the
final thing of our astrodb client secret
to so now let's go ahead and fill all
these out the open AI API key should be
easy it starts with SK like so we
previously saw this on the API keys on
open AI next I'm going to just put my
astrodb keyspace name which we also did
together I named the keyspace name
search so if you do the same as me just
go ahead and write the string search
there too of course this is all very
down to you if you're copying along with
me please feel free to copy these as
they are apart from the open AI API key
that would be unique to you it should
start with SK and if you try use mine
mine will now be deactivated or revoked
as I showed you how to do earlier as
well
next we're going to have our Astro DB
client secret so again this would be
unique to you here is mine if you try to
use mine it will not work for you but
I'm pasting in here like so so you can
kind of see the format that yours should
look like as well next we're going to
have our astrodb client ID which again
will be unique to you but it should be
kind of similar in length and kind of
similar in terms of the characters that
are used
and once again we have our token which
again is unique it should start with
Astra CS like so so make sure yours does
two but the characters after it will be
unique to you and finally we have the
path to our secure bundle so for this
just uh go ahead and go to your
downloads and find the ZIP file okay
that we downloaded when it came to
downloading a secure bundle and just
drag it into the project and once that's
dragged into the project I'm going to
ask you to get the path to it okay so
get the part like I am here and paste it
in like so as mine's in my project now
you will see the path to it in my
project which is stored in webstorm
project in the project called search
python so that's all I've done make sure
it is still a zip file so it will have
the dot zip extension at the end
and great so we are now done with all
those variables let's continue next
we're going to have to get some stuff
from the Lang chain package that we
installed so here's all the things that
we're going to have to get from Lang
chain so just paste that out like so
we're going to be getting Cassandra from
there we're going to be getting Vex the
store index wrapper we're going to be
also getting the open AI we're also
going to be importing openai as the
large language model and also importing
open AI embeddings from Lang chain
embedding
great as well as using the Lang chain
package that we installed we're also
going to get stuff from Cassandra so
what are we going to be getting from
Cassandra where we're going to be
importing the cluster and the plain text
auth provider and finally from datasets
we're going to import the load data set
from the package data sets that we
imported earlier
great
now we are going to essentially have to
write some configuration in order for us
to connect two data Stacks Astra and
create an Astra session and to do this
we are going to create a cluster so
using the cluster import I'm just going
to pass through two things I'm going to
pass through the secure connect bundle
which we can pass through as the
variable we defined above so that is
going to be passed through and another
thing we're going to have to pass
through is an auth provider okay and to
create an auth provider we're going to
use the plain text or provider that we
imported from Cassandra and pass through
our Azure DB client ID and astrodb
client secret so this is essentially
just configuration like I said in order
to be able to communicate with our
database that we created using
datastacks Astra okay so again we're
just using all these variables and
passing them through in order to connect
this to our Astra database
great
so once we've done that we have
essentially created an asterisk session
that we're going to be using later now
we're going to have to essentially
connect to open AI using our open AI API
key so we're going to get the openai
import and just pass through our API key
like so so we're getting the varial so
we're getting the variable that we
defined above and passing it through and
saving it under the variable llm
the next thing we're going to do is do
the same pool using the open AI
embedding so once again we're just
passing through our open AI API key and
we're storing all of this under the
variable my embedding great next we're
going to essentially create a table so
we're going to actually name our table
in here we are going to pass through our
astrodb key space which we know is the
string search and we are now going to
create a table and we're going to do
that my table is going to be called QA
mini demo so I'm passing through that
string that is being created and being
saved under the key space name of search
in my Cassandra database
great
so let's just check this is working
I'm just going to print loading data
from hugging face and then I'm actually
going to get some data from hugging face
okay this is just one that exists on the
Internet it's going to be some onion
news so I'm just going to load that data
set from hugging face and I'm just going
to pass that through and I'm going to
save it as my data set and then I'm
going to get that data and I'm going to
just get the headlines and in order to
check that has worked first off I'm just
going to print some texts okay so I'm
just going to print some text generating
embeddings and storing an astro DB and
then I'm going to add those headlines to
my Cassandra store so I'm essentially
passing that through to my database to
my astrodb database which is the
Cassandra database and then once that is
done I'm going to print those headlines
so let's run that code okay that's all
I've done I'm just printing stuff out to
appear in our console log so you can
kind of have this ability about what's
going on in the back end so once that's
done doing its thing we should get that
being printed so we're going to print
that text loading data from hugging face
so we can kind of see where we are in
the script essentially then we're just
going to print generating embeddings and
storing an astro DB and then it's going
to tell us exactly the amount of
headlines that we've inserted into
astrodb is going to be 50 headlines
great that is looking wonderful so we
can now continue now I'm just going to
essentially pass my store my Cassandra
store into the vexer store index wrapper
and save it under Vector index and now
I'm going to paste in some code
it's going to prompt us to enter a
question and once we have entered that
question it's going to do an if else
statement in order to print out the
question and then the answer as well as
the documents by relevance so
essentially we are going to write some
text it's going to search the hugging
face data so the onion news in order to
bring back any similar text it's going
to do a vector search on our database to
find similar text to it based on the
vector search so let's go ahead and do
that that is the code for doing so
please copy it and once we have finished
copying it just run the script and
you'll be prompted to enter a question
so now we can enter a question let's go
ahead and paste one that is what are the
biggest questions in science the answer
is I don't know so not a great answer
really but it's going to return some
documents by relevance in our database
so you will have here the relevant
document along with a temperature to
show you how relevant that document is
we have biologist torture amoeba for
information on where life comes from so
that's kind of similar to the question
that we propose and then we also have
study shows humans still have genes to
grow full coat of something so
essentially we are getting documents by
relevance that exists in our database
based on the question that we asked
let's try another one so I'm just going
to ask another question I'm going to ask
what should I know about Silicon Valley
Banks again it says I'm sorry I don't
know but then it returns some documents
by relevance again we get a similarity
score and then we also get the document
that is most relevant to the question
I'm going to ask one more let's ask one
about amoebas because I saw it being
returned in the first document so our
amiibos really are overlords and then
the answer is no amoebas are not our
overlords and again it returns documents
by relevance so we see that same
document being returned with a
similarity score that is higher based on
the question we can see that should be
higher because we do have the word
amoebas in there so there is no surprise
that that document is coming back with a
higher similarity score and then we also
have some other documents being returned
back with the lower similarity score
so great we have managed to build an AI
assistant that will essentially look in
a database look for similar documents
based on our question and if we want to
have a look at what this database looks
like under the hood so essentially has
been vectorized right we have vectorized
all the documents and then we are doing
a vector search on it to bring back
similar vexes to us that is exactly what
we discussed in the beginning of this
tutorial I hope you can now see how
Vector search works behind the hood as
well as on the front end to